- You mentioned, in an interview,
that science is not a collection of facts
but a constant human struggle
with the mysteries of nature.
What was the first mystery
that you can recall
that hooked you?
That captivated-
- Oh the first mystery, that's a good one.
Yeah, I remember that.
- What was it?
- I had a fever for three days.
When I learned about Descartes
and a little geometry.
And I found out that you
can do all the construction
in geometry using algebra.
And I couldn't get over it.
I simply couldn't get out of bed.
I- (laughs)
- What kind of world does
analytical geometry unlock?
- Well, it connects algebra with geometry.
Okay, so Descartes had the idea that
geometrical construction
and geometrical theorems
and their assumptions can be articulated
in the language of algebra.
Which means that all
the proofs that we did
in high school...
Trying to prove that the three
bisectors meet at one point
and that (laughs) okay.
All this can be proven by-
- Pure algebra.
- Shuffling around notation.
Yeah that was a traumatic experience.
- The connection-
(laughs) Traumatic experience.
- For me, it was.
I'm telling you.
- So it's the connection
between the different
mathematical disciplines?
That they all-
- (mumbles) to different languages.
- Languages.
- Yeah.
- So which mathematic
discipline is most beautiful?
Is geometry it for you?
- Both are beautiful, they have
almost the same power.
- But there's a visual
element to geometry, being-
- Visual...
It's more transparent.
But once you get over to algebra then
linear equations, straight line,
this translation is easily absorbed.
And to pass a tangent to a circle,
you know, you have the basic theorems
and you can do it with algebra.
But the transition from
one to another was really-
I thought that Descartes was
the greatest mathematician
of all times.